>>> DEMOCRATIC LAWMAKER JAMIE
RASKIN IS OUT WITH A NEW BOOK.
HE'S BEEN TALKING IN BLUNT TERMS
ABOUT DONALD TRUMP'S PARTY AND
WHAT HE SAYS IS CULT-LIKE
BEHAVIOR.
JUST LISTEN TO THE WAY HE FRAMES
IT.
TALKING ABOUT PEOPLE WHO ARE IN
DENIAL ABOUT JANUARY 6th.
>> I FEEL BAD FOR THOSE PEOPLE
BECAUSE THEY ARE ESSENTIALLY IN
A POLITICAL RELIGIOUS CULT, AND
THEIR CULT LEADER, DONALD TRUMP,
IS TELLING THEM THEY CAN'T
BELIEVE THEIR OWN EYES, THE
EVIDENCE OF THEIR OWN EXPERIENCE
AND THEIR OWN EARS.
SO WE SHOULD TRY TO EMBRACE
THOSE PEOPLE AND HELP THEM
THROUGH WHAT THEY'RE GOING
THROUGH BECAUSE THEY'VE BEEN FED
LIES AND THEY'RE SWALLOWING THE
LIES AND SOME OF THEM MAY HAVE
THOUGHT THEY WERE CLEVER AT THE
BEGINNING, THAT THEY COULD JUST
GO ALONG WITH IT AND NOT BELIEVE
IT, BUT MANY OF THEM HAVE
ALLOWED THE LIES REALLY TO SEEP
INTO THEIR SOLE AND IT'S
BEGINNING TO ROT THEIR MINDS.
>> TAKING IT EVEN A STEP
FURTHER, RASKIN TOLD "THE NEW
YORK TIMES" HE'S AWARE OF BOOKS
ABOUT CULTS AND DEPROGRAMMING TO
TRY TO UNDERSTAND HIS REPUBLICAN
COLLEAGUES.
HEARING THAT READING THAT MADE
ME WANT TO TALK TO DIANE
BENSCOTER, FIRSTHAND EXPERIENCE
WITH THE CULT MEMBER WITH THE
REUNIFICATION CHURCH IN THE
1970s.
SHE WROTE ABOUT HER EXPERIENCE
IN "SHOES OF A SERVANT: MY
UNCONDITIONAL DEVOTION TO A
LIE."
DIANE, YOU'RE AN EXPERT IN
PSYCHOLOGICAL MANIPULATION.
WHEN YOU HEAR SITTING LAWMAKERS
TALKING ABOUT CULTS, WHAT DO YOU
THINK THEY NEED TO KNOW?
>> I THINK WHAT'S REALLY
IMPORTANT TO UNDERSTAND HERE IS
THERE'S A DIRECT LINE OF WHAT WE
TRADITIONALLY THINK OF AS THE
MOST IMPORTANT DANGEROUS ASPECTS
OF A CULT AND WHAT'S GOING ON
WITH THE MASS RADICALIZATION
TODAY IN SOCIETY.
YOU CAN DRAW THAT LINE BETWEEN
THE CULT -- A CONSULT LEADER AND
ATTRIBUTIONS OF A CULT LEADER
AND ATTRIBUTES OF AN
AUTHORITARIAN LEADERSHIP LIKE
DONALD TRUMP.
ALSO YOU CAN DRAW A LINE BETWEEN
THE TACTICS, AND THAT'S THE MOST
IMPORTANT THING, THE TACTICS
THAT ARE BEING USED TO TAKE
ADVANTAGE OF PEOPLE'S
VULNERABILITIES AND HOW THEY
HOLD HIM THERE IS THE SAME AND
THE EXIT STRATEGY IS ALSO THE
SAME.
>> IS WHAT YOU SEE CURRENTLY
WITH TRUMP -- IT'S SO HARD TO
TALK ABOUT THIS HONESTLY, DIANE.
WE'RE TALKING ABOUT AMERICAN
NEIGHBORS.
DO YOU THINK SOME OF YOUR
NEIGHBORS IN THIS COUNTRY ARE
BASICALLY BEEN SUCKED INTO A
CULT, A POLITICAL CULT?
>> WELL, IN SHORT, YES.
I THINK THE WORD CULT, PEOPLE
HAVE THESE IDEAS OF WHAT A CULT
IS BUT, AGAIN, IF YOU POINT TO
THE TECHNIQUES, TACTICS USED,
THEY'RE EXACTLY THE SAME.
I THINK THAT PEOPLE ARE
VULNERABLE.
WE LIVE IN A TIME WHERE IT'S
HARD TO UNDERSTAND THIS WORLD.
TECHNOLOGY HAS MADE A HUGE
CHANGE MUCH LIKE THE INDUSTRIAL
REVOLUTION.
SO ANY TIME WHEN THERE'S SOCIAL
UNREST, I THINK PEOPLE ARE MORE
VULNERABLE AND THERE'S FEAR AND
THERE'S ANGER ABOUT WHAT'S GOING
ON IN THE WORLD, AND PEOPLE WANT
EASY ANSWERS TO THESE QUESTIONS
AND THEY GET SUCKED IN AND THEN
THEY GET CONSTANTLY FED BY ALL
OF THESE MEDIA SOURCES THAT ARE
FEEDING THEM THE MAIN MESSAGING
THAT CULTS DO, US VERSUS THEM.
BECAUSE IF YOU CAN FIRST DIVIDE
PEOPLE INTO US VERSUS THEM, YOU
CAN MAKE THE OTHER SIDE EVIL AND
WRONG, AND YOU KEEP FEEDING THAT
MESSAGING, EVENTUALLY WHAT YOU
CAN DO IS WEAPONIZE YOUR SIDE.
THAT'S WHAT'S GOING ON AND
THAT'S WHY THIS IS THE MOST
FRIGHTENING THING I HAVE EVER
SEEN AS I LOOK THROUGH THE LENS
OF CULTS AND RADICALIZATION.
>> WHAT I HEAR YOU SAYING ABOUT
POLITICS ALSO APPLIES TO
VACCINES AND DISINFORMATION
ABOUT COVID AND HOW PEOPLE WANT
EASY ANSWERS TO A COMPLEX
PANDEMIC.
SO IS THE ANSWER TO THIS
EMPATHY?
WHAT'S THE KEY WORD ANSWER?
>> YES, I THINK EMPATHY.
LOOK, PEOPLE COME TO MY
NONPROFIT FOR SUPPORT GROUPS,
PEOPLE WHO HAVE LOVED ONES WHO
HAVE BEEN RADICALIZED AND DON'T
KNOW WHAT TO DO, DON'T KNOW HOW
TO TALK WITH THEM.
THE FIRST PLACE WE WANT TO GET
THEM TO IS EMPATHY.
THEY NEED TO UNDERSTAND HOW
PSYCHOLOGICAL MANIPULATION WORKS
AND WE NEED EFFECTIVE TOOLS OF
COMMUNICATION TO AGAIN THE
PROCESS OF US VERSUS THEM
MENTALITY AND TRY TO TALK TO
THEM ABOUT THE POSSIBILITY THAT
THEY HAVE BEEN TAKEN ADVANTAGE
OF.
AND THAT'S A HARD CONVERSATION.
IT'S THE ONLY THING THAT WORKS.
IN MY YEARS OF HELPING PEOPLE
EXIT CULTS OF VARIOUS KINDS,
IT'S THE ONLY THING THAT WORKS
IS TO HELP THEM UNDERSTAND
WHAT'S HAPPENED TO THEM ON A
PSYCHOLOGICAL LEVEL.
>> I KNOW I SAID IT BEFORE, BUT
AS MUCH AS WE TALK TO POLITICAL
REPORTERS WE NEED TO TALK ABOUT
PSYCHOLOGISTS ABOUT WHAT
HAPPENED TO OUR COUNTRY BECAUSE
IT'S PSYCHOLOGICAL.
DIANE, THANK YOU SO MUCH FOR
BEING ON THE PROGRAM.
GO AHEAD, I'M SORRY.
>> THANK YOU SO MU